thank you
[Music]
two people were arrested in Florida
after one of them made a 9-1-1 call to
try to get help with moving the
belongings from a home they were
burglarizing
huh
I don't understand the English
so these guys are like yo man we gotta
Rob this house I'm like it's a lot of
[ __ ] dude what are we gonna [ __ ] do
like let's call 9-1-1 try to get some
help to help us yeah
they are public servants so they should
be able to help us oh dude there's a lot
of stuff to move huh these TVs are heavy
these days have you seen those big ass
TVs in Costco they're huge that's like
the size of a wall but it used to be
worse with rear projection you couldn't
steal a TV yeah you couldn't do it those
things are like this thick yeah you need
a furniture dolly yeah thank God the
thin TVs got thinner it only takes two
people to steal and instead of like a
whole team exactly
um so deputies responded to a home
Saturday after a 911 call was made but
nobody said a word
at the home deputies concluded nobody
lived there but they found a male
suspect his girlfriend inside the home
after entering it through an unlocked
door deputies began searching for the
male suspect and after identifying him
from a security video as a burglar at a
Dollar General store in Punta Cana
Florida where several items were stolen
earlier in the day
while talking to deputies the female
suspect told him that she called 9-1-1
for the purpose of having law
enforcement help them move their
belongings from the house they were
burglarizing
[Applause]
hoping to get a ride to the airport so I
could spend the weekend in New York dude
these people are off pills for sure
right like they're uh they're on some
sort of like yeah
tweaker Behavior that's the only way I
could rationalize this by the way the
deputies who arrived did help them with
their belongings and did give them a
ride but it was to prison
that's what the the sheriff's office
said in the cheeky Facebook how did they
know the how did the cops know that they
were burglars what's that how did the
community footage no but then like
before all that they call them up they
show up and were they still wearing the
burglar Maps why would you call the cops
to help you move furniture that's
probably how they knew something was not
dead giveaway well I don't know because
I think that's a good idea because they
always say like call the police if you
need help right we protect answers I
really need help right now this
[ __ ] have a feeling they just
looked the part yeah when they arrived
they're like okay good old typecasting
huh yeah
so the dollars
the house right so like they were
already looking for this they already
recognized their face and then they
showed up at this house and they see the
guy and his girlfriend and they're like
holy [ __ ] it's that [ __ ] guy from
Dollar Store you know what's kind of
strange too is that like I think we also
uh underrate how well cops know the same
criminals yeah like every time I've
called the cops on like a crazy person
breaking into that guy again they always
knew who it was because they always list
set and free so yeah exactly yeah you
know what I mean they did set them free
so yeah they're like you know why you
have to run right like because I gotta I
gotta catch it yeah I need to work next
week yeah I need some overtime it's a
mutual relationship between them you
know what I mean uh living in Glendora
we had a pretty big homeless problem
there and there's a guy that would
always try to break in and then uh I
heard him banging on my neighbor's door
and then so I went out to confront him
and I was like Hey like what are you
doing and he's like oh I'm here to get
the papers and I'm like what papers he
goes oh this guy owes me papers and he's
like looking through the windows and
stuff I'm like oh I was like if you if
you uh should I like text him I can call
him right now to just verify because I
don't recognize you and then he'll say
no no no no that's cool that's cool and
you kind of changed his tone a little
bit he's like no no I just just opened
his paper and get my papers and then I
was like oh you know what like um I
really want to help you so I took a
picture of him I was like I'll take a
picture yeah remember the picture you
sent us so I was like oh can I take a
picture of you I said it to me I was
like uh sure Nicholas he actually post
you posed for it I was like okay cool I
got your picture and see if it
recognizes you I was oh what's your name
by the way and he tells he tells me his
name later when I call the cops I'll say
hey there's this guy that's been roaming
around uh his homeless dude he looks
like he's trying to break into like
everyone's house and I go and he told me
his name was like yada yada even the guy
on that you know usually the
professional it's like okay and I go his
name is this and he goes ah
[ __ ] it's funny because he gave you his
real name yeah he gave me his real name
too so you took a picture of him or he
just gave you his Alias he's got like a
[ __ ] AKA that he gives all the time
apparently he's honest enough to get his
real name that they switched tone like
that yeah right away like he's a
professional professional and he's like
ah [ __ ] him God damn it yeah that's the
same exact reaction when we told the cop
that the uh the squatter across the
street from the house yeah when we were
like oh yeah she she told us that was
her house and they were like they looked
at each other
yeah dude yeah all the homeless people
on my street all the cops know yeah they
do right exactly and even when the guy
actually came he was like you know what
to be honest
we'll put them away this was gonna
happen yeah he's gonna be jail 48 hours
he's gonna stay on trial oh you guys do
48 hours over there something like that
and they're like they're gonna do that
they're like um he technically didn't
actually break and Enter he didn't
really steal anything
um all you do is just like scaring all
the housewives and [ __ ] so it's
technically not a crime so she'll be
back on the streets in a week yeah and
I'm like damn that [ __ ] sucks that's
why sometimes I miss street gangs
because street gangs if you're like like
not known in the neighborhood they're
like where the [ __ ] are you from and
then they just beat you up for no reason
so you don't want to go to that
neighborhood and he's scared yeah
they're like you know what no one else
should be burglarizing our neighborhood
the way that we should that we're doing
it that's why so that's why I like it
because it's like don't come and [ __ ]
rob the homes in our community those are
those are our homes and I I think that's
way nicer that was nicer back in the day
when you're on Street games where you're
just beating up homeless people
everywhere no the homeless people
weren't allowed to come
yeah they weren't allowed on the
premises for sure or what
I didn't do it
I didn't do anything I didn't do
anything I didn't do anything I thought
it was bad but you know what I've seen
allegedly let me give you all this info
and then don't ask me anything I no I
because I was I wasn't a part of a
street game I wasn't I was a that was in
a street game oh what game were you in
you're in a city game I was a wannabe
organized crime like most Asian gangs
were like not unless you're from Long
Beach in your Campbell like it wasn't
centralized in a specific because street
gangs are different like they like tag
up the neighborhood and then they like
have like Turf and then they fight over
that and I think like the way that Asian
gangs were like they were like the like
they're like the mafia and then they
became disorganized but they kind of
tagged up like certain areas and like
had like territory and stuff like that
too though right by this time of actual
Street King like like excuse me that
like 18th Street or whatever like they
actually live on that street and they
rep that where have you ever seen kanji
graffiti exactly exactly does your game
still exist
I'm not sure maybe yeah but the the
thing is I think a lot of Asian gangs
now the the people that were doing the
streaking stuff are now more organized
crime
it was like so the business
professionals like lawyers yeah they're
like mortgage mortgage Cafe because the
way that it always worked was like the
young kids were Aaron like doing air and
boy stuff until they became older and
then they joined the organized groups I
see but in the the kids my generation
were like copying all the stuff that
they saw like on like you know like
they're trying to be like Mexican style
black style like street gang style they
were copying the way they closed Calypso
sometimes they're popping the way that
they dressed but they they still didn't
do it the same way so they they had yeah
it goes all the way back to feudal if
Joe if you'd like to
[Laughter]
I think we
can get we can get through a couple
dynasties
can we talk about the history of lubu
how does that always get back to the
movies
I I remember okay you know how like
Chinatown now is like it it feels like
weird and gentrified and different right
I remember
um back in Japan Filipino Smash burger
places
so there were there were a bunch of
those flea markets right and and um and
and and the Protectors of it were like
uh these like Chinese mobster guys and
then me and my friends were just buying
five dollar I mean you get you get
t-shirts you get five for ten dollars or
some [ __ ] it was a like really good deal
we're just [ __ ] great deal looking at
it whatever and an altercation happens
like some guys were yelling at a street
vendor whatever and then this dude
he's like got like a members only jacket
and he goes like this and he just has
two [ __ ] guns like that and then he
just hands on his hips like looks at him
like that and everything
he looks like he looks like a dad he
looks like a dad and he does that yeah
he has a one-sided
it was like the movie it was like the
movie he goes like this he does that
Another Man shows up and then he does
one of these he has a [ __ ] like sword
or some like Chinese dagger or some [ __ ]
they just stand like this and then the
guys that were like yelling and stuff
they just go oh [ __ ] and they just walk
away and I was like that is the most
Mafia thing I've ever seen no trouble
we're just like wow do you guys got this
in the blue you know like we're like
that's pretty gangster though the big
this month is on me
that's crazy yeah but the the the the
the organized crime guys are the
security guys
and I was like that's crazy
all the security guys are organized girl
yeah but they you know they have a
uniform not yet it says securities
yeah I was like okay I was like that was
crazy man so Joe misses Street Kings
more ganks please yes it would help
clean up some of our homeless problems
where would they go I mean it would just
push them you live it up to the gangs
they have good policies you think the
gangs have um like the the mental health
training to be able to deal with them
if we're gonna talk about it yeah
they're all certified you know what I
mean they're all right re-elect Nick
Dunn guys they have the the protocols to
help the homeless people are you being
sarcastic because if you are you should
resign laughs
[Music]